they're trying to say that the
artificial intelligence Consciousness
would emerge from unconscious
ingredients and I'm saying that the
physicists are telling us that those
ingredients don't even exist when
they're not perceived it's time for
arthritis of Consciousness to recognize
that local realism is false physical
objects do not exist when they're not
perceived so they could not create
Consciousness so that version of
artificial intelligence giving rise to
Consciousness is dead through a zoom
screen I see pixels of your face those
pixels are not conscious or unconscious
so I also see pixels of of a wall behind
you and your face has given me insight
into your Consciousness I'm getting an
insight into what you think what you're
worried about what you're excited about
pixels on the wall give me no insight
into Consciousness my interface gives me
portals into Consciousness the good
portals are things we call human bodies
or my cat the cat body is a fairly Good
Portal into some Consciousness not as
good as human and enhance is a worse
portal a microbe is even worse and by
the time we get down to rocks and so
forth the portal is closed